The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: The aesthetic
of connection, this aesthetic
of familiarity, this
popular aesthetic operated
in Hollywood movies.
And I want to expand
a bit on this idea
by talking about
more explicitly what
might be called an
anthropological view
of this matter,
what could be called
the cultural work of movies.
One way I can make you think
about the larger and more
significant implications
of what the movies are,
of how to think
about the movies,
is to ask you to think
about the true implications
of certain words that we
just take for granted.
For example, take the
word entertainment
or the verb entertain,
to entertain.
We think of it
as-- we think of it
as a relatively
straightforward term, as it is.
And we think of entertainment
as some form of diversion
that takes us away from
the serious things in life.
But I want to suggest to
you that if we look closely,
even if we look at sort
of the root of the word
and the way the word is used,
and the variations on the kinds
of meanings that are
associated with the word
entertainment or the
verb to entertain,
we can see deeper implications.
For one thing, for
example, let's just
take a standard
dictionary definition.
There are three
different senses in which
almost all
dictionaries in English
would iden-- would define
the verb to entertain.
They would say, to hold
the attention of someone
is to entertain them.
A second meaning would be to
extend hospitality to someone.
That makes sense, right?
But think when
you extend hospi--
you're engaged in a communal,
in a hostly act, right?
It's an act of generosity,
an act of inclusion, right?
So forms of entertainment
are potentially
community creating, gestures
towards a community, acts
of hosting, right?
And they also, of course,
are a bid for your attention.
And then there's
a third meaning,
which is the most interesting.
To entertain, almost
all dictionaries
will tell you also means,
to hold in the mind.
I'm entertaining this idea.
I'm entertaining this thought.
I'm entertaining
this possibility.
In other words, the word
enter-- the verb to entertain
means to meditate, to think,
to speculate, to consider
possibilities, right?
And when you attend
an entertainment
in a certain sense, that's
exactly what happens.
Exactly because the
space of entertainment
is marked out by the society,
by social convention,
as a place of diversion,
as a place of relaxation,
as a place that is theoretically
not a place of work.
Certain things are licensed
or permitted because of that,
or encouraged.
Because you know
you're kicking back,
it's not a serious place,
what is likely to happen?
You're allowed, or at
least by implication,
or permitted to entertainment
possibilities that
in actuality might be scary
or disturbing or unacceptable.
So that one of the
ironies of entertainment
is that it can become a
space, especially public forms
of entertainment in
cultures, like Shakespeare's
public theater or likely public
theater of the American movie
system in the studio
era, these public spaces
can become spaces
in which the body
politic, the political
and social community,
entertains ideas
about its own nature.
Entertains, considers,
speculates, holds
in its mind accounts of its
origins, stories of its values,
right?
And what we can say, then, is
that the space of entertainment
becomes from, in a certain
angle, in virtually
all societies, a
space of discourse,
a space in which exactly
because it's a space recognized
as not real, as make believe,
is therefore licensed or allowed
to explore possibilities that
might be too dangerous or too
disturbing to explore
in other ways.
And we can see that certain
features of the entertainment
systems of most countries
and of most societies,
and certainly the
entertainment system we're
calling the Hollywood
studio movie,
are systems in
which other features
of the-- other
features of the formats
and organizational
principles of the films
reinforce this idea
that you're escaping
into a space that is also
a space of exploration
and discovery.
That you're not escaping and
running away exactly into forms
of diversion and hiding
from the world, but in fact,
you're escaping into
a space of freedom
in which you can
consider possibilities
that might otherwise be too
disturbing to think about.
And one way you can see
how the formats encourage
that comes back to
the argument I was
making about genres and stars.
Because think about, one of
the most fundamental things
about the conventions
of genre are
that audiences
understand not only
sort of the costumes
and the setting
and so forth, but also
usually understand
the basic-- what do we call
it-- the basic segments, a story
force, the segmentation
of the story,
the stages through which
the story is likely to go.
And they're likely,
in many cases,
to have a pretty good idea
about the nature of the ending
of a particular genre form.
They may not be absolutely
certain about the details
of how it will
work out, but they
have some pretty good
ideas about-- for example,
the notion is that
various forms of comedy
end on some sort of an
affirming or a happy note,
even if the difficulties
that are dramatized
in the text from the beginning
are very serious and troubling,
right?
Not that every single comedy
ends on a totally happy note,
but that's the
expectation you have
when you come to see a comedy.
You expect an adventure
with many difficulties
that are-- that will finally
be resolved in some form.
And in fact, traditionally, one
of the most fundamental ways
in which comic narratives
and comic dramas are resolved
is in the act of marriage.
Because of course, marriage
is a kind of reconciliation
of potential opposites.
It is a space of
celebration in which
different families
and different groups
and, in many forms of comedy,
different social classes
are brought together.
So that the marriage itself
becomes a social space that
replicates, if it's dramatized
on stage or in the movie,
it replicates in some
sense the communal space
of sharing that the
audience is engaged in when
it's watching the text, right?
So you have expectations
about the characters,
about the plots, about
the basic formats,
and especially about the
endings of genre forms.
Now what follows from
the fact that you
know that genre forms
usually end happily?
And indeed, that most--
that most Hollywood movies,
leave aside the
question of comedy,
will end on a reassuring,
or if not a happy, at least
a reassuring or a positive note.
You simply know that going in.
Even though that rule
is sometimes violated,
it's not usually violated.
And when it's
violated, it's often
violated in ways that are
instructive and interesting.
But you have that expectation.
Well, the expectation
that when you
get into the story,
the expectation
you have as an audience member
when you enter the story,
knowing that you are going to
come to a happy ending, what
does that do?
It's a form of reassurance
before you start.
There are theorists of
folk tales and fairy tales
who argue that that's one of
the functions of fairy tales.
That when a folktale
or a fairytale
begins, once upon a time,
many, many years ago,
in a land far away, and the
story ends, and they all
lived happily ever after,
what are the-- those
are ritualized or conventional
beginnings and endings.
What do they contain?
They may contain terror.
They may contain Little
Red Riding Hood being
raped or eaten alive, right?
But it's OK in a certain
sense, because when
you come to the ending, you
know that you'll be reassured.
So because you know that the
ending will reassure you,
it enables an
exploration of stuff
that would be scary
and frightening.
There are child
psychologists, for example,
who say that one of
the important aspects
of storytelling to
children is precisely this.
That the ritualized reassurance
of once upon a time and they
all lived happily ever after
are enabling conditions
that permit the
exploration, that
permit the story to
go into territories
that would otherwise be
frightening and terrifying.
What I'm suggesting
to you is that that's
a way of understanding
adult entertainment as well.
And over and over again,
the Hollywood film
will prove this principle out.
It will explore disturbing
and frightening materials,
but in ways that are some
sense legitimated or permitted
by the very fact that it belongs
in an entertainment space,
by the very fact
that it marks itself
as something that
is a diversion,
a mere entertainment.
But I'd like to
eliminate the word mere
because it's an inadequate and
derogatory way of describing
an experience that often
can be among the most
creative and valuable that
people in a society can have,
right?
So one way then of
crystallizing all of this
is to say that the
Hollywood film for me,
in the studio era
especially, represents
a particular form of what I
would call consensus narrative.
What I mean by this term is
something rather elaborate,
but I think very helpful.
What I mean by the term is
this, that in most societies--
perhaps not in all,
but in most societies--
all societies have
many different sites
of storytelling, right?
People tell jokes to each other.
We go to the opera.
We watch-- we play
video games that
are deep forms of
narrative today, right?
So that's the coming-- probably
the new form of narrative
that's emerging in our society
today, are video games.
We hear stories in theaters.
We can hear stories
in popular songs.
We read stories
in novels, right?
There are stories all over.
And in fact, we get
non-fictional stories out
of our newspapers and
from our politicians.
These are usually even more
outlandish, ridiculous,
and false than the fictional
stories that we're fed,
although we often don't
recognize that, right?
So we live in a sea, an
ocean of narratives, right?
All societies have many
different sites of it.
But in many
societies, if not all,
there usually is a single site
that by general acceptance
or consent is recognized as the
space in which the stories that
are being told are intended
for everyone, right?
The difference between what
goes on in a wrestling match
or in a baseball game, also
forms of narrative in a way,
or in an opera or in a
theatrical piece and a movie
of the Hollywood era, or a
television program in the great
era of television before,
say, 2000 when new systems
so atomized and divided the
television system that it began
to-- it began to imitate what
happened to its ancestors,
the films, a generation earlier,
losing its hold on the majority
of the population-- the
idea is then that the idea
of a consensus
story is the story--
it's the story form
or the story system
that the culture recognizes
as the one that reaches
the largest number of people.
And that by common
agreement or consent--
not by law, but by something
much richer and larger
than that, by a kind
of communal agreement,
this space is recognized as the
place in which the stories that
are told are meant to appeal to
the largest number of people,
cutting across social class,
cutting cross age and gender
differences, cutting
across ethnic differences.
Virtually all societies
have some space
in which some story system
of one kind or another
that wants to appeal to
virtually everyone exists.
Now it's important
to understand that I
don't mean it's a real
consensus, an authentic one.
That is to say, I don't
mean that the stories that
are told there really embody the
values universally of everyone
in the society.
Not at all.
Because these societies are
limited in certain ways.
They have exclusions.
They have caste
structures, and so on.
So the consensus
narrative in 1920
was a consensus narrative that
sort of saw African Americans
as second class citizens, right?
There was a lot
of prejudice then.
Or it certainly was a
patriarchal consensus,
which assumed that women
belonged in the home,
and so forth.
I don't mean that the
consensus is universally
embraced by everyone.
What I do mean, though, is
that everyone in the society
recognizes that this
is the consensus.
And even the people
who descend from it
recognize that this is the space
in which the central values
of the society are articulated,
dramatized, and diffused.
And what makes this
space-- these spaces--
so that another example,
I mentioned one earlier,
in Shakespeare's day, the public
theater of Shakespeare's time
was the equivalent of
what I'm saying Hollywood
was in the studio era.
In the Middle Ages, it
would be the Bible, right?
The central story promulgated
through all-- virtually
everyone in the
society had-- not only
had access to the Bible,
when they went to church,
they received further discussion
and elaborate propaganda
about how important and central
the Bible was to their life.
So the consensus
narrative system
was the one the church sustained
in the Middle Ages, right?
In fact, one of the
interesting things
is to watch in Western culture
the way in which the consensus
story becomes more
and more secularized.
And not only
secularized, not only
freed from religious
dispensation,
but also freed, in some
sense, in many societies
from government control.
Right?
So in some societies,
there is no such freedom.
So for example, the consensus
narrative in the Soviet Union
was the story that was
approved by the government.
It was-- and in fact, probably
the majority of the population
dissented from that
consensus, right?
So the consensus
I'm talking about
is always a
constructed one, right?
But that construction
is still interesting.
And this is one of the
exam-- one of the reasons,
for example, that
today people will still
scream bloody murder if
they see that on television,
the representation of minorities
or women is prejudicial.
But you don't see anybody
complaining about the fact
that there are such
representations in books
or in theater any longer.
And the reason for that
is that it's the consensus
system that matters to people.
It's the consensus
space in which
it is assumed the
values of the society
can be challenged
or discussed, OK?
So what I want to
suggest, then, is
we might think-- so we can think
of the Hollywood film then,
all Hollywood movies, as
belonging-- as participating
in the creation of what we
can call the consensus story,
the most widely shared story
about American society.
And it has many sides, right?
Part of the story has to do
with how you define masculinity,
right?
And some of that burden
is carried in every film,
but there are certain movies
like war movies or Westerns
in which masculinity, tough
guy-ness is the main issue.
And then there's some--
then we could say
the norms about family life.
Where do they come in?
Well, more often in
comedies and in melodramas
that focus on families, right?
In other words, different
parts of the consensus
are dramatized more fully
in different genres.
But all the films together
can be said broadly
to participate in a process
whereby the central values
and assumptions of the society
are rehearsed and repeated
and tested.
The central fact
about this process
is that it's never finished,
just like culture itself.
Culture's never a
fixed, finished thing.
This is one of the deep
insights of modern sociology
and anthropology.
I attribute it
primarily-- specifically
to the great English sociologist
and historian Raymond Williams
from whom I'm borrowing
some of the ideas
on-- although the word
consensus narrative is mine,
not his-- many of
these ideas are
drawn from Raymond Williams'
account of culture.
What he says is essentially
that culture is constantly
making and remaking itself.
That every time you watch--
think about-- some of you
can see this example more
fully with television
than with movies.
Remember, the
argument of the course
is that at a certain
point, sometime
in the 1950s or early
'60s, television
supplanted the movies as the
central form of narrative
in the American society.
Took over the job of being
the consensus, the purveyor
of the consensus, the
purveyor of the culture's
central values.
And in many ways, that
was a liberating moment
for the movies.
Our course dramatizes that.
This week, we're looking
at two screwball comedies
from inside the studio era.
Hereafter when we
juxtapose two films,
one will be from the studio era.
One will be from the era
after the movies no longer
carry the consensus,
the responsibility
to be the consensus medium.
That's been taken over by TV.
And the differences
are dramatic.
The differences are
stark and exciting.
Both forms are interesting.
The post-consensus forms
have great claims on us
because they're much freer.
They're not limited
or constrained
by what we might call the
central pieties of the culture.
The most obvious way you could
see this is in nudity, right?
They can show-- attitudes--
and dirty language, right?
Think about-- you can see the
stupidity and the arbitrariness
of these systems if
you think about how
television worked today.
If you put on an
American network show,
even a late night show by 10:00,
11 o'clock, at 9:00 or 10:00
a night, what you will get on
those shows-- you might get
things very different from
what you would have gotten
10 or 15 years
ago, but you still
won't get full frontal nudity.
You won't get women
taking off their clothes.
You won't see sexual activity.
You won't see very
much dirty language.
You used to see none of it.
But if you click the channel
one over and you go to HBO,
you could see the most
disgraceful pornography
that you can ever
imagine, right?
And you could hear people using
the F word so often that it
runs out of your ears, right?
And they're right next to
each other on the dial.
What explains the difference?
HBO doesn't belong to
the consensus system.
The networks are still
a vestigial survival
of the old consensus system.
And if you think about the
difference between network
television, even today, and the
movies or network television
and what's on HBO
or Showtime, you
will see this distinction
with great clarity, right?
So one of the things
that this means
is that these systems
of consensus narrative
have a tremendous
claim on our attention.
They're more important,
in some sense,
in a sociological or
anthropological sense
than other forms that don't
bear the burden of having
to tell the story, the
consensus story of the society.
You remember I said
culture's unfinished.
So are these stories, right?
The great thing about them
is that they change, right?
That over time, they'll alter.
I'll come back to this
question next time
when we talk about the Western.
We talk about how
the Western alters
over time in ways
that are tremendously
responsive to problems
in the outer society.
A very clear example of the
way in which genre constraints
can enable an exploration
of serious subjects.
So we'll return
to that next time.
For our purposes tonight,
the primary point is this.
What the advantage
of these consensus--
one of the advantages of
these consensus systems
is that they can review a great
deal to us about the societies
they serve.
We can say in a certain sense
that the work or the job,
the anthropological function
of these consensus systems
is to help the society
figure out what it is.
So that one of the things
that happens in these stories
is that-- and here
I'm borrowing directly
on Raymond Williams-- we can
think of a consensus narrative
as a discourse space, as a
space for conversation, right?
Thinking of also
remembering that genre,
in one way or another,
could be thought
to carry some sub-category or
some sub-element of the larger
consensus.
So masculinity and warrior
behavior, and certain forms
of honor and courage
are dramatized
in war movies and Westerns.
But certain aspects
of family life
and of the relation
between siblings
and of the relationship
between parents and children
are dramatized in forms of
melodrama and comedy, right?
And detective stories
sometimes explore
the social and
political implications
of particular societies more
systematically and fully
than other forms.
But so take it all together.
The different genre
forms may be said
to lay different emphases
on the consensus,
but they all contribute
to the consensus.
And one way they contribute
is by constantly showing us
fissures and disagreements.
They don't all tell
the same story.
What they tend
to-- and this helps
to explain why movies are often
either incoherent or partly
contradictory, right?
Movies are not simple,
stable, unitary things at all.
One reason is they're made
by so many people, right?
There's no single author.
There's a director,
a writer, actors.
There's an army of
subsidiary people who help.
Films are profoundly
collaborative form.
And one of the effects of
this is that in some forms,
the director's control
may be imperfect,
and the star may distort the
film in some way, or take it--
or in some films, the writer
may be so powerful and so
imaginative, and the
director's relatively
weak that a different kind
of movie emerges, right?
So movies are
different in that way.
And then, of
course, they're also
different because they occur
at different moments in time.
And those moments--
when they occur
in different moments
in time, even
if they belong to
a particular genre,
they may be responsive to
later problems in the society
from ones that differ
from the problems that
may have been the case 10 years
earlier when the genre-- when
a different version of
the same genre story
would handle the
characters or the story
in a somewhat different way.
So what we can say,
among other things,
is there's a tremendous
value to the idea,
to the recognition that
not only is culture
always unfinished
or always sort of
struggling to figure out
certain kinds of conflicts
and difficulties, but that
our consensus narrative
systems are also a
space that accommodates
that kind of disagreement.
And one way to
conceptualize this
is to see that in
almost all films,
and certainly the
whole system, could
be said to dramatize
or give voice
to three different strains
or perspectives on society.
One is what might be
called a traditional voice.
That is to say, these
are old-fashioned ideas
that are still powerful,
but they really
belong to an older era.
The second kind
of voice you hear
is what we could call
the dominant voice.
That is to say,
the central values
that the majority of the people
in the society now believe,
right?
A little different
from traditional voices
that are more old-fashioned
that are becoming vestigial.
And then on the other side,
emergent voices, right?
New ideas, new attitudes
that are coming through.
And you can feel
this in every film.
You can feel this in
every television program.
If you look at American
television from the 1950s
to the 19-- say '90s-- let's
say you've restricted yourself
to situation comedy.
What do you think you would see?
You would see a drama in which
the American family undergoes
profound change.
What happens?
Women become more important,
patriarchal values
become less and less powerful,
children become more respected,
are treated less like
appendages to the family.
And by the '80s and '90s,
sometimes the children
have more dominant
roles than the adults
and are often even shown to
be wiser than their parents.
Something that would
have been impossible
in the early 1950s, a
more patriarchal era,
when the classic television
program about families
was called Father
Knows Best, right?
Whereas in later episodes,
the father not only
knows-- doesn't know
best, he knows least.
Or sometimes he's
completely gone,
and it's women who are
raising the children, right?
Well, what's going
on in that process
has to do with the way in
which the feminist movement
and a reconfiguration
of our idea of gender,
our ideas of gender and
family-- what's happening
is the situation comedy is the
space in which those problems
are being dramatized over time.
And if you juxtapose a sitcom
from the '50s and a sitcom
from the '60s, and a sitcom from
the '70s and one from the '80s,
you can actually see
that drama being enacted
in tremendously powerful ways.
I choose examples
from television
because I want to choose
examples more of you
are likely to have your
own experience with.
But I could offer such instances
from the history of movies
as well.
But almost none of you would
have sufficient experience
with the movies to
understand the examples.
So that's why I've chosen
examples from television.
I hope some of you at least--
well, I know many of you
can't, because you didn't
grow up on American television
either.
But some of you at
least can get the idea
that I'm talking about here.
So the notion that-- so
this is a way of explaining,
for beyond what the intentions
of any particular movie
maker or producer
would have, it's
a way of explaining
and clarifying
the profound historical and
anthropological importance
of the movies in
American society.
And by implication,
in other societies
as well because the argument
applies in different ways
to those societies as well.
The notion is not that
movies are unimportant today.
But they occupy a different
niche in our consciousness
and in our daily lives than
they did in the Hollywood era,
in the era of the
Hollywood studios.
OK.
Capra and Hawks
can be said to be
two characteristic instances,
two characteristic examples
of really journeyman
directors from the studio era.
I had intended-- let's put
up the other-- I actually
had intended and had planned
to give you a much more
elaborate, sort of brief
biographical accounts
of each director.
But I don't have
time to do that.
And what I'm putting
up instead here
are just a list of
some of their films.
You can see what a
journeyman Hawks was.
He made very important
screwball comedies.
Probably the dominant
figure in screwball comedy.
Classic Westerns.
I've listed some of them there.
And he was also be a great
director in other genres.
He worked-- it was very
interesting that he could
work across genres in this way.
He may be the most diverse
of all the classic Hollywood
journeyman
professional directors
because he worked so well
across so many categories.
There are recurring themes
that show up across genre
in Howard Hawks' work.
And I'll mentioned some
of them in a little while
when I try to introduce
His Girl Friday,
one of his great
screwball comedies.
Capra operated in
a slightly more--
a slightly narrower range.
But like Hawks, he was
an immensely successful,
immensely popular
director during an era
when the studios
were essentially
operating like gigantic
factories in which the studio
heads where the primary bosses,
and in which each studio,
especially the five major
studios as well as many
of the smaller ones,
were essentially
small cities, small factory
cities for the manufacture
of movies, right?
Not just that they employed
dozens, if not hundreds
of-- well, they
employed hundreds, even
thousands of workers
of different--
but they employed dozens
of writers and dozens
of directors, and they had
dozens of stars and actors
on contract, and they
owned great lots.
And of course, they had
an army of technicians,
of grips and best boys
and camera people,
and post-production people
and publicity people,
and various other factotums
who took care of people.
And they probably had a
more elaborate encyclopedia
of gophers than any other
industry in history.
But the point is, in a
sense that each studio was
a kind of manufacturing
hub, was like
a great factory, the equivalent
of General Motors or Chrysler.
But instead of making
automobiles or toasters,
they were making these things
that infiltrate our dreams.
A product I think much
more powerful, disturbing,
and interesting, even than
the most remarkable automobile
or toaster.
Two other things I should
mention about both Capra
and Hawks, because they
share this quality,
and they share it with
Hitchcock as well.
They began their careers
in the silent era.
They made a transition
to the sound era.
Capra was a more successful
silent director than Hawks,
but both had experience
in the silent era.
Unlike some directors,
were able to make
a very successful transition,
along-- as Hitchcock
also did, and became major
directors in the sound era.
The other significant thing
to mention about both of them,
they both spent
time in the Army.
They both kicked around.
They were not sure they
were-- it wasn't as
if when they were
born they said,
I want to be a movie maker.
They had all kinds of
uncertainty in their lives.
They almost fell
into movie making.
But there's one thing
I think all of you
will find interesting.
And I love to mention
this to my MIT students.
Both Capra and Howard
Hawks studied engineering.
And Capra, in fact, got
an engineering degree
from the University of
Southern California.
When he couldn't get work
as a mechanical engineer,
he began to cast around
for other things,
and he ended up in the movies.
Howard Hawks didn't graduate,
but he studied engineering
at Cornell.
I think he never
graduated from Cornell.
But he studied
engineering seriously.
And I don't think it's an
accident that these directors
had engineering experience.
Because there's an
organizational intelligence,
a practical
intelligence, even genius
that every good director--
not to say great director
needs-- that is very will served
by an engineering education.
So I encourage all of you,
when you finish your degrees,
to go to Hollywood
and become directors.
I won't say more
about Capra and Hawks
now except to say again
that they represented
a certain sense, the center of
what a Hollywood director could
represent in the era of
the studios, in the era
when the movies where the
dominant form of entertainment
in American society.
I want to say a couple of
things about each of the movies
that you're seeing tonight,
the two different screwball
comedies.
One by Hawks, one by
Capra, each representing
a characteristic tone
of each director.
As I said earlier, you can think
of Capra as a slightly more--
as a somewhat more sentimental
and optimistic director.
If you want a
quintessential-- a scene
that sort of distills this
sentimental populism--
a sentimental populism is a
good way of describing much
of Capra's work--
there's a scene
in It Happened One Night that
captures this quality in him.
You can feel that-- you can
feel its optimism and perhaps
its fakery.
But you want it to be
true, even though you
know he may be imagining a nicer
humanity than actually exists.
There's a scene on a bus
in It Happened One Night.
A good deal of the film
or a good part of the film
takes place as
people are traveling.
It's a road film,
in a certain way.
And there's a scene on a bus,
a number of scenes on the bus.
But there's one
very powerful scene
in which all of a sudden, after
a certain dialogue occurs,
the people on the
bus sort of rise
up and begin to sort of
create a little musical number
themselves.
Watch how it happens.
And it's almost as if
these strangers suddenly
become members of
a musical troupe,
and they begin to
interact with each other.
It's a fantasy of
community that has
all kinds of sentimental,
affectionate assumptions in it
that is no doubt
an exaggeration,
but it tells us something about
the sentimental populism that's
at the heart of Frank
Capra's vision of life.
Let me say quickly a couple
of words about each film now.
It Happened One Night is not
the first screwball comedy,
but is the film that
established screwball comedy
as a dominant genre.
There are films going
back probably to 1930,
if not earlier, that
could be identified
as screwball comedies.
And there are certainly
films-- full screwball comedies
that existed before
It Happened One Night.
But the success of It Happened
One Night nailed the genre,
made the genre a popular one.
And I want to mention a
couple of production notes
that are kind of interesting.
One of them is this.
Both the stars in It Happened
One Night, Claudette Colbert
and Clark Gable, had had
significant careers before they
came to make It
Happened One Night.
Gable had been in movies
for over a decade.
He'd been in a whole
number of films.
But he was a second
rate-- a secondary player.
And he was a difficult man.
He was resisting assignments
that he was being--
he was under contract
to the MGM Studio,
which was the most elaborate
and wealthy of all the studios.
And the head of
MGM, Samuel Goldwyn,
was annoyed with Gable,
because he was uncooperative.
They were sending him
scripts he didn't want to do,
even though he was
under contract to them
and theoretically had to
do what they told him.
And because he annoyed
Goldwyn, Goldwyn
decided to discipline him.
And the way he disciplined
him is we said, all right.
I'm assigning you to Frank Capra
who works for Columbia Studios.
You have to make a film
that he's working on.
You have no choice.
You're under contract to me.
Gable was incredibly
angry about this.
One of the reasons is Colombia
was not a major studio.
It was a low-budget studio.
Capra was not yet a
widely known director,
even though he had been
directing since the silent era.
Gable felt that he was
being imposed upon.
He was very reluctant
and angry about the job.
The star, the female
star, Claudette Colbert,
was also reluctant
to take the job.
She had been in--
she was a stage star,
and she had been
successful on Broadway.
But she'd had a checkered
career in the movies,
some bad luck in the movies.
She'd made a film
that was panned.
She was very reluctant
to make any more movies.
And when she was
asked, she resisted.
And she finally agreed only
when they doubled her fee.
She normally would get
$25,000 for a film.
This time she got $50,000.
But even when she accepted
this, she still was reluctant.
She said, OK.
I will do this, but I
have to be free to go
to spend Christmas with
my friends and family
in Palm Beach.
The shooting has to stop
no-- I will not work
late-- longer than December 23.
And so they had four very
intense weeks of shooting
in which they-- in which
they did their best
to finish the film.
And they didn't quite finish it.
But Claudette walked off
the set and said, I'm done.
My contract-- I fulfilled
my contract, and she left.
Capra hadn't yet filmed the
final scene of the film.
When you watch the brilliant
final scene of the film, which
Capra had to do
without his stars
because Colbert had
walked off the set,
you will see a
magnificent example
of what we might call necessity
being the mother of invention.
Because it's a
brilliant, rich scene,
but he had to do it because he
didn't have his actress there
in order to make the scene.
So watch for it
when you come to it.
Another point about-- when
Colbert left the film,
she was said to say
to friends, I've
just completed--
I've just finished
the worst movie of my life.
This is a horrible film.
Gable was angry about
the film, and thought
it was a piece of garbage.
In the advent, the
film was the first film
to win Academy Awards
in every major category.
It won for best film.
It won for best actor, best
actress, best director, best
screenplay.
It was the first film to notch
all five victories, right?
Like, it's better than a
hat trick in hockey, right?
Like a perfect game
for a pitcher, right?
The best-- very few films
have ever done this.
And it turned every one of the
major participants in the film
into major Hollywood players.
After this film,
Gable became what--
came to be known as
the King of Hollywood.
And for a decade and a half,
he was the top-grossing actor
in Hollywood.
And all of his great work
follows after this film.
He was in a series of
classic Hollywood films
to the very end of his
life in his last film
with Marilyn Monroe.
Anyone know what it--
written by Arthur Miller?
A film called The Misfits,
his very last film.
He was dying when he
was making that film.
It's very moving film.
You can see that he's
dying of cancer in the film
if you look closely.
But he had a magnificent career.
He was one of the
characteristic,
central, iconic actors
of the studio era.
And this is the
film that made him.
There's a moment
in the film when
you see Gable and
Colbert discussing--
they're forced to
share a motel room,
and this is very
risque in the 1930s.
Man and woman together,
unmarried in the same room.
And in fact, they
have separate beds,
but it's a very small room.
And she's nervous about it.
And one of the
things he does is he
puts up a line across the
room of, like, a clothesline,
throws a blanket over
it, and he says, OK.
We'll stay on either side
of the wall of Jericho.
And you'll see how
the wall of Jericho
works out in the final
scene when it comes down.
And there are moments where
you could see the Colbert
character very nervous about
the fact that she's alone
with a strange man in a motel
room, and she's at his mercy,
in some sense.
And there is a kind of
[INAUDIBLE] about this.
And there's a moment where we
see them getting ready for bed.
Gable takes off his shirt, and
he's not wearing an undershirt.
He's only wearing
an outer shirt.
And it is said-- it
has been said so often
I can't resist
mentioning this to you,
even though I can't
confirm it absolutely.
But it's mentioned so
often in the scholarship
that I want it to be true.
It is said that the sales
of undershirts in the United
States plummeted after
it was discovered
that this actor wasn't
wearing an undershirt.
(GRUFF VOICE) Because
that's what men do, OK?
But there is a larger
context for the film.
The film takes place
during the Depression.
And even though it's a comic
film about two apparently
mismatched creatures who will
come together in the end-- can
you guess from the
scene in Ball of Fire
what's going to happen to Gary
Cooper and that sexy woman
by the end of the film?
Of course you know, don't you?
Why do you know it without
ever having seen the film?
Because that's what
comedy does, right?
The conventions
of comedy do that.
And part of the pleasure
in watching that is to say,
look how different they are.
Look how frightened he is.
Look how aggressive she is.
How could they
ever get together?
But of course you
know that they will.
And part of the pleasure
in watching the film
is watching them get
over those barriers.
Well, the same thing happens, as
you'll see, in tonight's film.
But the gap between the Gable
character and the Colbert
character is not just
gender male and female.
It's also a class difference.
She belongs to
the upper classes.
She has no experience with
the outer world at all.
She's lived an incredibly
protected life.
So that when she comes
to terms with Gable,
she's coming to terms not
only with certain inherited
forms of class prejudice.
She's also overcoming a certain
kind of innocence and naivete
about her relationship to men,
and her relationship maybe even
to her own sexuality.
So the film is a bildungsroman.
You know that word?
Novel about growing up?
About this woman who lived
a very-- lives a very
sheltered life.
She's a very spoiled rich girl.
And the drama of the
film is she becomes,
in a certain sense, begins to
discover her own real nature,
begins to discover
something about her own--
about her own character
and about her own capacity
to judge the outer world.
She's very limited
and foolish earlier.
The context of the film,
then, is a dramatization
of this relationship.
But the background of the
film is the Depression.
And as you'll see, this
sexual and marital adventure,
this comedy of marriage,
or eventual marriage,
takes place against a backdrop
of suffering and unhappiness
and misery.
And it imparts a resonance
and an importance to the film
that it wouldn't otherwise have.
Because there are scenes
in these trailer homes
where the Colbert character,
completely unused to having
to live a life like
that of ordinary people,
is suddenly forced to confront
what such lives are-- what
such a life is like, and
it's part of her education.
So the context of the
Depression is important.
A second fundamental
thing, as I've already
implied by my anecdote
about the undershirt,
is that the Gable
character came to stand
for an ideal of
American masculinity.
In the scene where he is first
introduced, he's half drunk.
And it's important for you to
understand the context here,
because it's not exactly
celebrating drunkenness.
Although it partly is, I
mean, he's a man's man, right?
We see him get drunk and
talk on the telephone
to his editor boss,
who fires him, right?
And he staggers out
of the phone booth,
and he's talking to his friends,
and he says, I'm the king.
This is where the word-- where
the term the King of Hollywood
originates, in the lines
that you see in the film.
But it's important for you to
understand that part of what's
going on here-- it's 1934.
Prohibition has just
been lifted, right?
And what's being dramatized
there, it's illegal for him
to drink for the first time
in whatever it is, a decade.
And the film is partly
celebrating that, right?
So you're not supposed
to think of him
as some ridiculous
roustabout drunkard.
You're supposed to
recognize that what's partly
being dramatized there
is the new freedom that
has emerged in American
society now that Prohibition
has been repealed.
And in that scene you
can see something--
because his half drunkenness, we
do see some of his inhibitions.
You can see something of
his true nature there.
And what you
discover is-- and you
can see this come out elsewhere
in the film too-- something
that the Colbert character
at first can't recognize.
That he has a heart
of gold, that he's
a decent, admirable
person, that he would never
treat anyone badly.
But he's also very
self-reliant, and no one
can push them around.
He's a particular kind of--
represents a particular kind
of masculine ideal, right?
He can't be intimidated, but
he'll never mistreat someone.
He has a kind of moral compass
that guides his behavior, even
though it's implicit, right?
He's a bit vulgar.
He's suspicious of
wealth and pretension.
The Gable character
came to stand
for a particular kind
of American masculinity
that was celebrated over and
over again in American movies,
a kind of-- a type
of the American male.
I've already said that one of
the things the film does also
is dramatize a romance
across social class.
And you might want to think
about the way in which
the-- in almost all comedy,
and certainly comedies that
involve-- comedies
about marriage,
comedies about men and women,
almost all such comedies
involve some notion of barriers
of some sort that are placed
in the way of the consummation
in which the text wants to end,
right?
And those barriers
can take many forms.
But one of the most fundamental
forms they take over and over
again is the barrier of class.
And one of the things
that the Colbert character
and the Gable character
both have to do
is get over their
prejudices, get over
their blind spots about
the social classes they
have less understanding of.
One of the most moving and
powerful aspects of the film,
and I think you'll see
this really powerfully,
is the way in which
the audience comes
to have an understanding
of the characters that
exceeds that of the characters.
And that there
are many moments--
there are many moments
in the film in which you
will understand how
the characters are
feeling before they are able
to acknowledge it themselves.
You can see them falling
in love, for example,
without them being able
to admit it to themselves.
And it's immensely-- think of
what an immensely subtle trick
that is, to put the viewer
in possession of information
or knowledge that the characters
themselves don't have,
and what a rich
kind of knowledge
and ironic perspective--
a rich kind of irony
that generates for the
viewing of the film.
"A marriage of true minds" is
a famous sonnet by Shakespeare
that begins, "let me not to
the marriage of true minds
admit impediments."
The impediments to the marriage
of true minds in this film
have to do with the characters--
the Colbert character's naivete
with the prejudices and
self-reliance of the Gable
character, with the social
realities of the Depression.
And these barriers
have to be overcome.
But "a marriage of true minds,"
what could the phrase mean?
A marriage of equals,
a marriage of people
who are not different.
The deepest thing I
love about this movie,
and the reason that I've come--
that I treasure this film, even
though there are many
old-fashioned qualities in it
that make it feel old and
distant, in some sense,
from contemporary society is
its understanding of-- it's
the implicit, idealized
understanding of marriage.
Because what the film
really wants to suggest
is not that-- first of all, it
suggests that these people are
drawn to each other sexually.
It's not embarrassed by
the fact that they're
both physically beautiful people
and that they feel attraction
for each other that
they can't themselves
fully acknowledge or deal with.
But the second kind of
attraction they have
is a mental attraction.
They realize that they're both
deeply intelligent people,
that they're both people who
are deeply verbal, that they
both have improvisatory powers,
intellectual powers, that
distinguish them
from other people.
That they're made for
each other, essentially.
There's one scene
that shows this.
Before they realize
it, we realize it.
It's a wonderful scene.
They're hiding out in a motel.
And at a certain point,
she's on the run.
Her rich father is
searching for her.
And the Gable
character's a reporter.
Says, I'll protect you and
help you if you give me your--
if you let me have an
exclusive story, because she's
such a rich heiress
that she's big news.
So she agrees, and he's
escorting her north,
hiding from the people who
are searching for her, right?
And at a certain point,
they're in a motel.
Some private cops knock
on the door of the hotel,
and they come in, and
they're searching for her.
And watch what happens.
What Gable and the
Colbert character
do is they immediate--
Gable says, follow my lead.
And then when they
come in, they begin
to play husband and wife
having a tremendous quarrel.
And you can watch-- you can see
that they're improvising it.
And you can see
they're enjoying it.
And you can see how well
they play with each other.
So in other words, it's
a moment in which you
can see that it is a
marriage of true minds,
long before the characters
themselves fully
recognize how they are
meant for each other.
That's a wonderful
moment in which
their intimacy and there
appropriateness for each other
is dramatized.
It's not only a physical
or a sexual thing.
It's also an intellectual
and a moral and mental thing,
a psychological thing.
They are-- it will be a
marriage of true minds
if they can come together.
I want to end-- just
finally mention-- I've
mentioned the ending already.
And I'll just say
one more time that,
watch how the ending works out.
And you'll see a
magnificent example
of a director dealing with
contingencies he could not
possibly have anticipated.
And it's a wonderful example
of a kind of inventiveness.
Seems to me, the film ends
as well as it could end.
And it's better that
the actors aren't there.
But he certainly--
when this happened,
I'm sure that Capra thought
it was the end of his film
and that he was--
didn't know what
he was going to do
to try to finish
his film without
his star actress.
I have to be even briefer
about His Girl Friday,
but I think it's a more
straightforward film
in some respects.
It's a much less
sentimental film,
and I hope you'll recognize how
deeply-- how much more deeply,
unsentimental, even cynical,
or at least deeply tough minded
and suspicious, skeptical
Howard Hawks is about all
of the operations of the world.
Not only about
individual human motives,
but about all
human institutions.
Virtually everyone
in His Girl Friday
is a cynical,
self-seeking creep.
Even the primary characters,
the Ros Russell character
and the Cary Grant
character have
intriguish, manipulative
elements in their natures.
And you can see especially
that the Cary Grant
character is, in some respects,
a very nasty piece of work.
He does terrible,
terrible things
to poor Ralph Bellamy, the
man that Ros Russell is
supposed to marry, her fiance.
He plays a sort of straight,
sweet, straightforward kind
of person, very much in
love with his girlfriend,
but completely--
how can we put it?
But he's a dummy.
He's stupid.
And even though he's very nice,
you don't really like him.
You think he's a jerk.
The film makes
you mean or nasty,
in some sense,
because it makes you--
it makes you see things from the
perspective of the Cary Grant
character.
It encourages you to be
tough minded and skeptical.
And you do come away from
the film thinking, oh, gee.
I've participated
in the humiliation
of this poor, decent guy.
But anyway, he's deserved it.
He's such a stupid mark, right?
You can't-- you almost can't
help that kind of reaction.
The film is based
on what had been
a very successful
play on Broadway,
some generation earlier.
And that play was made
into a film in 1930
that was quite successful,
directed by Lewis Milestone.
But the Hawks film is the
classic version of it.
And Hawks does one thing
that's very important,
that changes the
original, changes
the play in a fundamental way.
In the original
play, the character
played by the Rosalind
Russell figure in the movie
is a male character.
And the great discovery or
the great transformation
that was wrought in the
film by Howard Hawks
was his decision to
turn that character,
a guy named Johnson, from a male
Johnson into Hildegard Johnson.
Hildy, Johnson, the character
played by Rosalind Russell.
And as soon as he
turned her into a woman,
he created his screwball comedy.
He created a wonderful
kind of antagonist
for the Cary Grant character.
I've already indicated
to you how many films
in different genres
Hawks directed.
Remember that list I
put up there was not
a complete list at all.
It was a selected list.
But it was some of the
most important films
by each director.
And one of the things that's
really interesting about Hawks
is that he directs Westerns
and screwball comedies
and private eye
films and war movies,
and a range of other lesser,
sort of no-genre films as well.
And yet in all of them, there
are certain throughlines.
You can recognize
certain recurring themes
across these radically
different films.
And one of the most fun--
and one of the way-- one
the most fundamental
impulses in a Hawks
film, whether it's a Western
or a war movie or a screwball
comedy, is an impulse
to slow things-- well,
not to slow things down
exactly, because his dialogue is
so rapid-fire.
But to sort of stop the
plot, to interrupt the story
with a scene of argument.
He loves scenes of quarrel.
He loves scenes of
discussion, of talk.
He loves talk.
And especially, he
loves intelligent people
quarreling with each other.
And there's never
been a director better
at eliciting from his actors
quick, rapid-fire dialogue.
In fact, he developed a
strategy for doing this.
He used to sit right
next to the camera.
He didn't stand
behind the camera.
He had a cameraman.
But he sat right
next to the camera,
and he had his
actors play to him,
only sometimes very close
to him as they were acting.
And if you watch, especially
some of the scenes
in this film, you will
see what astonishingly
realistic performances
he got from his actors
by this strategy.
He even encouraged certain
forms of improvisation.
He would run through
rehearsals first,
and then he would encourage,
when he began to film,
scenes-- he would encourages
his actors to improvise
and to improvise to his face.
And he creates a kind
of electric authenticity
in his dialogue scenes that
has a tremendous authority.
So the character plot
I'm talking about
is this impulse to
slow the plot down
or to stop the plot for scenes
of argument and conversation.
And what constantly
happens, whether he's
making a Western or
a screwball comedy,
is his characters
stop the action
and say, oh, what do you
think is going to happen next?
If I do this, what
will happen then?
As if the films
begin to generate
a kind of meta-commentary
about their own nature, right?
So they're incredibly
talky films,
and the dialogue is fundamental
to your-- the rapidity
of the dialogue is fundamental
to your understanding
of the characters and to your
understanding of the larger
film.
So his central scene then is a
scene of quarreling intimacy.
You feel that
they're quarreling,
but you also feel that no
people could quarrel exactly
in this way if they weren't
also intimate with each other.
And you'll see fully
how it works out
when you see the film itself.
So finally, I want to
say at least a word
to remind you how it
actually-- although he's
tremendously entertaining line
by line and scene by scene.
And never calls--
such a professional.
He never calls
attention to his camera.
He's a very quiet
filmmaker in that sense.
A real journeyman,
a real professional.
He doesn't want you to think
about him or his camera.
He wants you to think
about what you're seeing.
There are limits
to this strategy,
and we'll talk about
what the limits are
when we look at certain
other directors who
behave in other ways.
But there are also
great strengths
to this, as you'll see when
you watch tonight's film.
And something of his
complexity is embedded here.
Because what you can
find is he creates
scenes of immense comic energy,
really generates real laughter.
But beneath the
laughter, there's
a deep layer, a deep
substrate of cynicism,
of skepticism,
about human motives,
about the virtue of
human institutions,
about the capacity
of human institutions
and individual human beings for
corruption and misdirection.
There's a kind of deep
political and social cynicism
in the film that
doubles the comedy
or complicates or deepens
or roughens the comedy,
sours the comedy,
in a way that makes
for a particular
kind of complexity.
It's possible to argue,
which some critics have,
that this film, more than
any other that Hawks made,
combines laughter and
cynicism in unique measures.
And I think together, these two
films and these two directors
can mark at least a
certain pole, certain poles
in the tradition of
Hollywood filmmaking,
and especially in the
tradition of screwball comedy.
You can feel the pull toward a
kind of sentimental, affirming
impulse in Frank Capra,
and the pull toward a kind
of cynical, distanced,
complex, psychologically
deep, politically
informed laughter,
even mockery in Howard Hawks.
And they represent two
aspects, two elements,
almost poles within the larger
story of the Hollywood studio
film.
Enjoy the films.